en este vídeo lo que quiero hacer es
introducir o más bien debería decidir
redondear un poco porque ya platicamos
un poco de eso pero bueno quiero
redondear las ideas keynesianas este de
aquí es john maynard keynes antes lo
pronunciaba como 15 porque así se
escribe en inglés pero es john maynard
james él era un economista que hizo casi
todo su trabajo así más famoso durante
la gran depresión hace en los 30 es
porque desde su punto de vista pues el
modelo clásico no estaba sirviendo para
explicar este fenómeno de la gran
depresión para entender un poco más sus
ideas vamos a comparar el modelo clásico
así el modelo clásico de demanda
agregada y oferta agregada con uno que
es un poco más quinciano ya platicamos
un poco no perdón keynesiano dije que
inicia no verdad uno que es un poco más
que inician para si te decía ya
platicamos un poquito de algunas ideas
keynesianas pero lo que quiero hacer
ahorita es realmente comparar ambas
formas de pensar ambos modelos
económicos ahora no es para decir que
uno es mejor que el otro ni nada por el
estilo de hecho game pensaba que a largo
plazo el modelo clásico estaba bien pero
que también dijo que a largo plazo todos
están
muertos por otro lado tampoco es para
defender el modelo keynesiano osea hay
algunos puntos buenos de lo que él dice
pero hay algunas otras escuelas que son
un poco dogmáticas pero bueno tienen
buenas razones para descartar el que
inicia mismo después practicaremos un
poco acerca de eso pero en este lo que
quiero hacer es simplemente entender la
economía keynesiana y pues como sigue es
muy contrastante con respecto a la
economía clásica entonces en la economía
clásica voy a usar demanda agregada y
oferta agregada lo voy a poner por aquí
entonces aquí tenemos precio por aquí
tenemos el producto interno bruto real
el pib real también lo voy a poner aquí
en el caso keynesiano que aquí es precio
acá tenemos también el producto interno
bruto real real ahora en ambos casos
tenemos una curva de demanda agregada
hacia abajo esto es por pues razones que
ya platicamos en vídeos anteriores
verdad dejarlo dibujo así demanda
agregada y acá también tenemos demanda
agregada algo así
recordemos que en el modelo clásico a
largo plazo a largo plazo
la capacidad productiva de una economía
la producción si vamos a decirle la
producción no debería depender del
precio entonces ya vimos que a largo
plazo la curva de oferta se vería algo
así la oferta agregada a largo plazo
oferta agregada a largo plazo a veces lo
puedes ver así va entonces dice mira o
sea los precios simplemente son una
forma en la cual el mercado dice pues
qué quiere la gente verdad que a final
de cuentas tanto el dinero como los
precios nada más son para facilitar
transacciones basa el trabajo te pagan y
usas ese dinero para comprar otras cosas
que genera la economía como comida el
transporte y otras cosas entonces el
dinero nada más es una forma de
facilitar las transacciones pero la
economía en teoría basada simplemente en
la tecnología en su capacidad productiva
en sus fábricas y en sus recursos
naturales pues va a producir lo que
tenga que producir entonces si cambiamos
la demanda agregada verdad si digamos el
gobierno imprimirá dinero y aventar ese
dinero
por un helicóptero para distribuirse lo
a la población entonces la demanda
agregada se iría hacia la derecha verdad
y qué sucedería pues esta línea vertical
sigue siendo vertical entonces el efecto
neto es que no cambia pues no cambia la
producción pero el precio cambia de este
precio de equilibrio a este de acá
arriba y entonces el precio aumenta es
decir experimentamos inflación sin tener
una producción pues mayor ahora pues hay
varias formas de mover esa curva de
demanda agregada hacia la derecha verdad
puede ser con una política fiscal donde
el gobierno no se pues deja sus ingresos
por impuestos constantes pero gasta más
o no se podría hacer al revés
o sea podría que sería o sea no
cambiaría su gasto pero disminuye los
impuestos cualquiera de esos dos mueve
la curva de demanda agregada hacia la
derecha y bueno en este modelo clásico
dice que a largo plazo eso no va a estar
padre sólo va a aumentar los precios
lleva inflación y la única forma en la
cual podemos mejorar la economía es
haciéndola más productiva o sea no se
haciendo algunas inversiones en
tecnología o haciendo la economía más
eficiente haciendo crecer la población
no sé a algunas de estas formas
la única forma es pues moviendo la
oferta verdad moviendo la oferta de esta
línea de acá hacia la derecha y bueno
quien dijo eso está bien pero estaba
sentado en medio de la gran depresión y
dijo sabes que hay un montón de gente
pobre ahorita en los 1930 las fábricas
no desaparecieron y la gente tampoco hay
fábricas los que quieren producir ig y
gente que quiere trabajar verdad pero
pues ninguno de esos puede hacer su
trabajo porque las fábricas no les piden
y la gente que podría producir más pues
estaría produciendo riqueza que no está
siendo demandada pues quien dijo
seguramente aquí hay algo raro con la
demanda agregada especialmente en el
corto plazo de hecho en el muy corto
plazo entonces en un muy muy corto plazo
digo ya platicamos un poco pues de una
oferta agregada a corto plazo que tiene
pendiente positiva y es algo que se
vería algo más o menos algo de este
estilo a mí me gusta pensar un poco más
en algo intermedio esto de aquí ya tiene
algo que ver con ideas que iniciadas
pero bueno entonces vamos a pensar en un
muy muy corto plazo y entonces que es
dijo sabes que con los precios ahí van a
estar muy rígidos entonces especialmente
déjame escribirlo por aquí
a corto plazo de hecho debería de
ponerle muy corto plazo entonces a muy
corto plazo especialmente cuando la
economía está produciendo muy por debajo
de su capacidad n en una situación así
digamos durante la gran depresión
entonces los precios van a ser rígidos
son rígidos o sea no van a cambiar mucho
y eso tiene un poco de sentido intuitivo
verdad si la economía se sobrecalienta y
la gente quiere que la fábrica produzca
mucho ya está produciendo casi a su
total capacidad entonces las personas
van a empezar a cobrar más y van a pedir
un aumento pero si no tienen trabajo
entonces van a estar van a estar urgidas
por trabajar entonces si la fábrica está
trabajando digamos al 30% y alguien
quiere pues comprar más cosas pues no es
un buen momento para pedir aumentos
verdad como tienes trabajo conviene
trabajar ahí más y entonces en un muy
corto plazo todo será muy fácil entonces
a muy corto plazo que ellos tiene ideas
totalmente contrarias al modelo clásico
dice sabes que para cualquier nivel de
producto interno bruto a corto plazo el
precio no se va a cambiar déjame lo
pongo algo así entonces en este modelo
de acá esto de aquí sería la oferta
agregada
en muy corto plazo lo pongo aquí con tu
plazo y bueno podemos debatir que es
corto plazo muy corto plazo pero pues
podría hacer días no sé semanas meses o
un par de años pero bueno si empezamos a
ver al mundo de esta forma entonces pasa
algo interesante a la izquierda la única
forma en la cual podemos aumentar la
producción es modificando la oferta pero
por este lado de acá la única forma en
la cual podemos aumentar el producto
interno bruto es modificando la demanda
por ejemplo con una política monetaria
imprimiendo más dinero o bien con una
política fiscal disminuir impuestos y
dejando el gasto igualito oa lo mejor
hacer ambas cosas verdad puede generar
un déficit ya sabes podrías este
disminuir los impuestos y gastar más
pero bueno eso movería la curva a la
derecha y eso podría hacer que aumente
el producto interno bruto ok y entonces
game dijo sabes que osea mira los
economistas clásicos dicen que en un
mercado libre la economía llega a su
punto de máxima eficiencia así nada más
naturalmente pero que nos dice pues si
eso a veces pasa
pero a veces no pasa vamos a ver algunos
casos después o sea yo no creo que el
modelo que inicia no sea ideal en todas
las circunstancias ni siquiera creo que
quien lo haya creído depende muchísimo
de las circunstancias por ejemplo que es
presenta la siguiente situación tenemos
a tenemos ave hace y ha de personas o
compañías y supongamos que a le vende
ave se le vende hace
se le vende a d y de le vende a a y pues
no sé digamos que cada uno le vendía dos
unidades de cualquier bien o servicio
que esté ofreciendo y bueno por alguna
razón no sé supongamos que se de repente
que comía unos tacos que le cayeron mal
tuvo pesadillas despertó con el pie
izquierdo y dice sabes qué pero la
verdad no me siento muy bien de la
economía a lo mejor debería de hablar un
poquito y en vez de comprar dos le voy a
comprar uno bueno pues me va a decir
chin mi negocio no está yendo muy bien
entonces también le voy a comprar uno
a hacer lo mismo de hacer lo mismo
llegamos hace y se dice guau debo de ser
un profeta pero en realidad pues fue una
profecía autocumplida verdad o sea el
pesimismo de cee causó esto van a operar
así y puede que no haya una forma
natural de regresar al estado en el que
estaban sin alguna intervención externa
digamos bueno especialmente una
intervención gubernamental a lo mejor el
gobierno puede decirle a ver pues te voy
a comprar dos temporalmente ahora hay
muchos peligros y después vamos a hablar
de eso pero bueno alguien más digamos el
gobierno le puedes decir a ver vamos a
mover la curva de demanda
te voy a comprar la unidad que falta es
el gobierno y entonces me dije que ya
puedo comprar dos también puede comprar
dos de también y entonces las cosas
regresan a su estado original en un
mundo ideal y esto es importante para
evitar los peligros que dije el gobierno
diría ok ya todo está bien ya no tengo
que comprar esto de aquí pero es muy
difícil pues que el gobierno deje de
gastar en algo que ya empezó a hacer
porque es impopular bueno esta de aquí
es la idea general detrás de el
pensamiento keynesiano contra el
pensamiento clásico es mira hay
circunstancias como la gran depresión
donde la economía está operando muy por
debajo de su potencial y en esas
circunstancias tenemos que aplicar un
estímulo al lado de la demanda y no al
lado de la oferta ahora yo creo que la
respuesta correcta es considerar algo
intermedio verdad déjame dibujo un
modelo que me gusta un poco más están
mis ejes de precio y de producto interno
bruto real ahí está y entonces pues
déjame poner otra vez aquí la curva de
demanda agregada hacia abajo algo de
este estilo y entonces yo creo que la
forma que se ve más precisa sería algo
así supongamos que esto de aquí es el
del máximo absoluto teórico así si todas
las fábricas estuvieran funcionando
hasta dónde llegaríamos algo por aquí y
supongamos que por aquí está el
potencial o sea es un estado saludable
donde la economía puede estar operando
ahora la la verdadera curva a mediano
plazo de oferta debería de verse deja
aquí pongo la de largo plazo oferta
agregada a largo plazo ok entonces yo
creo que el mejor modelo sería algo
intermedio se vería algo de este estilo
una curva que déjame ponerla con otro
color
los americanos entonces se vería algo de
este estilo más o menos
algo así entonces si por alguna razón
alguien tiene una pesadilla o muchas
personas tienen pesadillas o pues pasa
algo con la demanda agregada no sé
digamos el mercado de valores este
quiebra entonces pues la demanda
agregada se puede mover para acá y aquí
pues parece ser que las ideas
keynesianas si son buenas verdad estamos
muy por debajo de la capacidad de la
capacidad de producción y entonces si
parece ser una buena idea aplicar un
estímulo para mover la demanda a la
derecha por otro lado si estamos
produciendo bien y el gobierno hace un
poco de políticas que inician us y
después vamos a platicar porque al
gobierno le gusta hacer políticas
keynesianas aunque no estén muy
justificadas en el momento entonces la
demanda agregada se va a mover como por
acá y el efecto neto y bueno mientras
mayor sea la inclinación mayor va a ser
cierto esto el efecto neto es que van a
aumentar los precios sin realmente tener
una mejor producción entonces depende
muchísimo de las circunstancias y por
esta razón pienso que una curva que se
ve así es mucho mejor
o sea que empieza haciendo así como
aplanada y luego empieza a tener una
mayor y mayor y mayor pendiente justo
refleja la idea de que la política
depende de la situación y entonces
combina bien el modelo clásico con las
ideas
iniciales